RETO MEIER: It's
officially week eight
of Google Cloud Next
on Air, which means
we're focusing on Cloud AI.
I'm Reto Meier, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud,"
where we're taking a sneak
peek at this week's content.
Week eight is all
about Cloud AI,
meaning we want you to see
how AI can help everyone
on your team.
There's all kinds of talks
this week that cover everything
from infrastructure to
train AI and ML projects all
the way to managed
offerings that give you
the benefits of
ML without having
to train your own models.
So check out all
the talks this week
and add interesting
sessions to your playlist
so you can watch them on demand.
And speaking of
managed offerings,
this week, we're
shining the spotlight
on measuring and improving
speech-to-text accuracy.
While the speech-to-text API is
already great out of the box,
you may have custom needs for
your industry or use case.
So this talk walks
you through how
you can customize your
model, improve accuracy,
and even features a lab
where you can try it out
for yourself.
One session I'm
super excited for
is Interpreting ML Models
with Explainable AI.
No matter what the
accuracy of your ML model,
it can be hard to
know exactly how it
comes to that prediction.
Thankfully, this talk
covers Explainable AI,
which puts the
tools in your hands
to help you increase your
model's transparency.
If you want to learn how to
use Explainable AI and the What
If tool to better
understand your models,
make sure to add this
one to your playlist.
Finally, have you had a
chance to check out Kaggle?
It's a fully customizable
notebook environment
where you can get access to
all the code and data you need,
as well as access all sorts
of learning opportunities
and competitions.
This week also
features a session
talking about how Kaggle
transitioned from GPUs to TPUs,
so check out that talk
and get hands-on with ML.
To add these sessions to
your digital playlist,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas,
leave us a comment
or tweet us using the
hashtag #GoogleCloudNext.
We'll see you in the cloud.